hey guys our post got liked by PewDiePie
very epic we're gonna watch that first
and we're gonna watch the rest of the
video which I shot before I knew any of
that had happened so yeah bit weird but
here we go
when I joined Jake Paul's course say
were entitled and lazy I thought it
would be trash but I also thought a lot
of people would have joined boy was I
wrong I was the only one in the entire
site
nobody was watching his videos nobody
was participating in the community tab
unless who was to ask how they could
cancel their subscription I was
disappointed in my fellow Jake Pollard's
but more than anything I think I just
wanted a friend so with nothing else to
lose I sent out a final SOS as something
of a mating ritual for my fellow Jake
Pollard's to see if anyone's left out
there 24 hours nobody responded finally
at long last big ballers if you're tired
of all the hate for Jake Paul like this
post smash like I'll be the first one
gentlemen we got him berry epic
pewdiepie and one with video so I was
originally gonna make a video on Jake
Paul and I even had a login I had had
gotten an account to his new financial
freedom movement scam but then everyone
called it out for what it is and so I
was thinking okay no I'm not gonna you
know tread over tread over stuff that
people have already talked about that
was until I logged in yesterday and
found a porn star on the front page of
Jake Paul's community tab yes this is a
14 hours this is this post has been up
I'm gonna go ahead and blur it for you
guys because I don't want to get
demonetised but rest assured this is
here in all its glory for everybody who
wants to log in your kiddies want to log
in your kiddos you little tot tots want
to log into Jake Paul's new course well
this is what greets them yes now you
might be saying to yourself well hey
it's a community I'm Jacob Paul has no
control over that which is kind of true
but if you're gonna make a community
which you know people can post whatever
they want but you also know that a bunch
of kids are gonna be on there you have
to moderate it and they have a report
feature which is like you know report
this is I guess inappropriate or
whatever but apparently no one's
actively moderating it to make sure I
mean who knows what this could be
because the fact they didn't take it
down means they're not watching at all
cuz anyone would take this down as soon
as they saw it so this could be I mean
straight-up hardcore porn I mean it
could be anything right now I don't know
how many people signed up for the
financial freedom movement but what I do
know is that Jake Paul has actively
targeted kids with this community I mean
he has something in his in his sales
letter where it's called the letter to
parents okay if you are already paying
for Netflix or Hulu or Amazon Prime then
this is a no-brainer those things aren't
helping your child with their future are
they
whereas for only $19.99 a month your
child your child has access to
world-renowned experts who have taught
and impacted over a million students
around the globe now maybe Jake Paul is
keeping his promise when he says your
child has access to world-renowned
experts who have impacted over a million
students around the globe but I don't
think maybe he means that in the way he
thinks he does I think he's keeping his
promise in a whole nother way entirely
when you look at the front page of this
community tab and this leads us to it
into a larger conversation around Jake
Paul this guy is a branding disaster
because after seeing this I was like I
wonder what other ridiculous thing Jakes
Paul has done and I saw immediately On
February 10th he posts a picture of a
dildo on the front of his car on Twitter
to his 3.7 million followers most of
which are kids to which I responded and
I said oh yeah that's a kid's channel
and I linked one of my friends at nerd
city and this guy Mel put forward an
interesting argument he said he stopped
being PG for like a year now get over it
which raises an interesting question
could it be that Jake Paul merely has a
residual young audience but does not
want said young audience and he's
reinventing himself for some I guess
adult figure or something like that
someone with more edgy content so this
is acceptable because he stopped he
reinvented himself for whatever now one
thing is true
Jake Paul is definitely aware that he
has a kid audience you've never
performed in front of a crowd older than
16 I don't get why this is a bad things
I have a younger audience right there
ladies he knows exactly who his audience
is I have a younger audience he's like
yeah that's my audience I
however then you have him posting videos
like this my ex-wife hooked up with my
girlfriend when the first 29 seconds you
have a nip slip which did not go
unnoticed by Jake Paul's audience 28
that nipple flashed though and again I'm
censoring it Jake Paul didn't which
whatever I mean kid audience right hit
audience and then then he's got a girl
joking about well I'm not even to say it
never sings I'm not trying to get this
video team on it's at more demonetised
than it already is
and only at this point does Jake Paul
decide oh maybe this is a good time to
tell my young impressionable audience
that this video maybe shouldn't be
watched by them so this is what a minute
22 into his video if you're watching go
over to Ryan's Tory review this is rated
R now this is kind of incredible for
promotable reasons number one you can
manually rate your content r-rated and
you can say this is not a perfect for
kids and age gate the video for people
older than 18 did Jake Paul do this
because we would be able to see it if he
did it would say age restricted no he
did which means he's fine with kids
watching he only wants to give the
plausible deniability of like oh I said
it but you said it after a nip slip
pantomiming you know that's when you
said it right and at this point maybe
our friends comment it comes into play
in maybe he just doesn't want that
audience and is trying to reinvent
himself but that's also not true
see Jake Paul he likes the fact he has a
kid audience because he knows they buy
stuff right that's why he has the
financial freedom movement that's where
he's selling to kids he likes the fact
that they buy all his merch but he also
wants to be seen as cool and interesting
and edgy so he also makes really adult
content but we know he hasn't given up
on his young audience because not only
does he sell to them actively even
though he doesn't put parental controls
anywhere in place he also actively
targets them with content this is a
video made on December 28th on his
channel Jake and Titus where he
collaborates with a kid and this is
called Jay Paul verse tightest
gingerbread house challenge now I won't
bore you with this whole video but let's
just say there's a demographic clearly
being targeted here and it's not adults
it's not for edgy teens it's for kids
this is kids content so he clearly
continues to target a young demographic
because presumably they make great
consumers right he's writing letters to
their parents saying hey get your kid my
course
get this go watch my youtube channel go
do this go to that and yet at the same
time he's making adult content that is
wildly inappropriate for your children
which makes him a nightmare because you
don't know whether which Jake Paul is
gonna be that day is it gonna be the
Jake Paul that does have to eat happy to
exploit kids parents for their credit
card information I mean I don't know is
it gonna be the Jake Paul that has porn
stars on his the front page of his
website is gonna be the Jake Paul that
has a nip slips
in the first part of his video which is
not age gated even though he admits that
it definitely should be a video that's
rated R but only says that after
pantomiming this and frankly I'm shocked
that this stuff still is going on you
can't have like you can't do this well
actually this is living proof that you
can do it but maybe I should say you
shouldn't do this what a disaster dude
what a disaster oh and his course sucks
too
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
for the car
[Music]